with some talented comedians.
J Smitty, Reece Cotton,
and Jay Are Adams.
All right.
Let's talk comedy, man.
What do you guys think about
the comedy scene here in Boston?
I actually like it, you know.
It's just a hop, skip and a jump
to Rhode Island, Connecticut,
and even New York, and even
New Hampshire has a little, you
know, comedy scene.
So we're perfectly located,
you know, to go all over.
This is probably one of the
best places to start comedy,
because it's a good mix.
Like, there's a lot
of college kids here.
So it's a weird kind of thing
we've got, where we've got
like, some of the
smartest people here,
but we've got the old
townies, so we've got some
of the dumbest people here.
OK.
So this city has a lot--
a lot of range.
How do the comedy scene that's
outside of the comedy clubs
here?
People will start
their own rooms.
They'll talk to the
bar and be like, hey,
we'll do a comedy night here.
It might start free.
If it gets good, maybe they can
start charging people $5, $10,
$15.
So it starts as just
you work with a bar,
and then it becomes something
that it's a good club.
OK do you guys frequent
those spots a lot?
We frequent a lot.
A couple of nights, sometimes.
There you go.
That's why we don't
really need a huge club
or a huge casino,
because we have
a lot of people that really
love comedy in the small rooms,
and it works.
The people-- people
here love to laugh.
That's what I like about Boston.
They come out ready to laugh.
Bombing moments.
I've been--
I've been lighted early.
KEVIN HART: OK.
[laughter]
Like, real early.
Did they flick it?
When they flick the lights,
that's when it's getting bad.
When you see the guy in the
back just looking at you.
It ain't been, like,
five minutes yet.
He told me 15.
I've gotten the early light.
I've also bombed and just took
it, and was like, I don't care.
I'm just going to get through,
say what I have to say.
And I sat down, and then the
owner got up and was like,
yeah, you know, she's actually
a really good comedian.
And I'm just like,
wait a minute.
Oh, God.
Not good.
Wait a minute, I don't--
that just made it worse.
What's the end game?
Like here's where I am, but
here's where I want to be.
Well, first, I need to get
my brakes fixed on my car.
So like, just $100 for that.
To me, this is a
big stepping stone.
This is a big opportunity
for us, and you know,
we've been dreaming
of meeting you.
You know?
I was watching Netflix.
I saw "Laugh At My Pain" I
saw how big that crowd was,
and I was just
like, I want that.
You want that.
There you go.
And I was like-- and that's
as far as my dreams have gone.
KEVIN HART: As far as you saw.
Yeah, as far as I see.
We're at Slade's Bar
and Grille tonight.
I can't wait.
I'm excited.
I think you're going to
make Boston proud, man.
Get up there and kill tonight.